Speaker 1: The scary part is that Herschel
Walker had a chance and he almost won.
I've been saying now for months that Herschel
Walker never should have even had a shot in
a country that made sense with voters with
some connection to reality.
Someone like Herschel Herschel Walker never
should have even won the Republican nomination
in Georgia to be senator, never mind getting
49% of the vote roughly in the general election
in Georgia, which is what happened in the
runoff.
And there's a couple of good articles and
one that I want to highlight in particular
that makes this case.
Jack Holmes wrote a couple of days ago in
Esquire.
Herschel Walker lost, but it's a very bad
sign that he had any chance at all.
There was a shark in the pool and nobody got
bit.
But why were so many people cheering for the
shark in the pool?
And the article makes points that are not
altogether surprising.
But the point that we've been making and that
Jack Holmes makes is that although it's a
good thing that Herschel Walker lost, he barely
did.
And the fact that he almost became one of
100 senators in the United States is certainly
emblematic and indicative of a much bigger
and scarier problem in the United States.
And in the article, Jack Holmes writes, It
feels almost unnecessary at this point to
run through Herschel Walker's record as a
national political candidate.
He's running in Georgia, but said in a campaign
speech he lives in Texas, etc., etc..
But as you read down the article.
It explains the answer for a lot of people
to the question why make Herschel Walker a
senator seem to be that if Walker wasn't elected,
those people, Democrats, Marxists.
You know, who the hell knows would control
the Senate?
And by the time that the election came up
on Tuesday, that was no longer the issue,
because we knew that at minimum, Democrats
would have a 5050 majority with Kamala Harris
as the tie breaking vote.
And so it became more about who gets power
and who do Republicans vote for and what are
the principles here and who are the backers
of this guy?
And when you zoom out and you think about
what happened, you realize that this was really
the worst of the worst of Republican politics
at this point in time.
What do I mean by that?
Well, it's basically at least three different
things.
Number one, for many Republican voters and
for the GOP establishment, the RNC, at the
end of the day, it's simply about is there
a Democrat that we can prevent from winning
somewhere?
It doesn't matter who we put in place.
So the No Democrats ever is a big part of
this.
And later on in this in this part of the show,
we're actually going to look at a Republican
who is saying it's not about no Democrats
no matter what.
It actually does depend who the Republican
is.
And Mitt Romney is that guy.
We'll get to that a little bit later.
So you've got the.
But listen, war knocks a Democrat.
We can't have that.
That's number one.
Number two, you have the MAGA non MAGA split.
So it has to be acknowledged that.
The other factor here is that Herschel Walker
is sort of a MAGA cult type candidate.
And as we know from following Trump in 2016
and 2020 and into 2022 midterms, through his
endorsements and now as a 2024 candidate,
it is a cult.
And one of the things about the cult is when
the cult leader tells you this is the guy
in this particular case, you accept that,
you accept that, and you don't question it.
And Donald Trump said this is the guy and
it failed, fortunately, but the MAGA cultists
accepted it.
So that's another layer to this.
You've got better than a Democrat no matter
what cult candidate.
Okay.
And then you have the third part of this,
which is the voters more broadly.
And this goes beyond cult or not cult, but
it's the general problem in the United States
of how there really is no bar.
There's no.
Speaker 2: Bar for.
Speaker 1: The majority of the Republican
electorate.
Big picture.
Now, that doesn't mean they'll literally vote
for anyone in a primary.
But Trump 2016 was instructive of that.
Why did Trump run as a Republican and not
as a Democrat?
He really was, at least loosely speaking,
a Democrat.
It seems most of his life, but it was because
there is some standard on the Democratic Party
side.
It's not anyone can get the nomination, just
if they come up with the right things to say,
even if they completely contradict 68 years
of their lives, as did Trump on issues of
religion and abortion and other things.
The Republican Party has no such bar, and
so because of that, we saw that they were
gullible enough to go for it in 2016 and then
it was sort of a path dependance that got
them there in 2020 as well.
Those are really the three things that this
is about.
And as it applies to Herschel Walker, we're
all glad he lost.
Herschel Walker in the U.S. Senate would be
a humiliation to this country and it would
be a humiliation in so many different ways.
Great.
We dodged the bullet and not by very much.
I think it's important to say under 100,000
votes, if I recall incorrectly.
But he had a shot.
And as we saw in 2016 with Trump, sometimes
you don't dodged the bullet.
And then in 20, we did dodge it.
And so let's not take away there's people
emailing me saying we made it, we made it.
The 2022 midterms.
They weren't as bad as they could have been.
Yes, they weren't as bad as they could have
been, but they were almost so bad that they
could be that bad or worse in 2024.
We don't want
to allow that
to happen.